and this show i'm doing now is the same
way i get
recognized from it all the time it's a
romantic
drama based on romance books it was the
first time netflix ever went into that
genre right
and it has become it's the fourth
most streamed
show in the world
in the world really yeah
it's huge i gotta watch this they
well it's
you know it's it's may not be your cup
of tea it's very very romantic and slow
what are you saying no i'm saying
something i can't be romantic you can't
but you like horror movies no i mean i
mean i i watch i could watch anything if
it's good it's good it's very very well
if you're in it i'll check it out i'm
gonna watch kidding for sure oh you've
got watch kitty it's beautifully
produced written acted by wonderful and
tim matheson who i've known for for
forty something years as we play
opposite one another and we have a great
time um
and yeah we're gonna do another season
soon they've they've announced it so i
can say it netflix is very i want you to
be very careful what's the show it's
called virgin river virgin river and
where can they find it netflix on
netflix yeah how do you like working for
netflix they're great really they're
great they uh they have writer first
refusal on everything i do so anytime i
want to do anything even a play i have
to go you have to ask them and ask them
but they're great they've never said no
you can't the only thing i think they
would not want me to do is is uh like a
another mini series on showtime or hbo
not that i've been asked right but um
you know that would conflict with them